[Música]
nossa tia avó isa é cega e foi com ela
tiveram o nosso primeiro contato com o
braille é um alfabeto onde pode sentir
as coisas estão escritas durante as
férias a gente passou uma tarde com ela
em que elas ficam como funcionava nos
mostrou as letras números e símbolos e
tentamos ensinar mas não deu muito certo
porque é super complicado ética porque
sendo dito por um tempo mas quando
voltaram às aulas
eu comecei a ficar entediado em algumas
aulas e decide voltar a estudar braille
eu comecei a escrever as letras a partir
de pontos meu caderno e acabei
memorizando alfabeto e fiz muitas e
muitas vezes e deixa de comprar uma
reglete que é uma máquina que permite
escrever em braile na qual você pode
acabar se escreve que mostram relevo
eu acabei deixando meu caderno minha
agenda de letras de música nome de filme
eu fiz isso muitas vezes eu também
troquei várias cartas que minha tia-avó
isa em que eu escrevi pra ela que estava
aprendendo a me dava dicas e com isso na
passagem do 1º e 2º ano descobriu que a
gente poderia participar de um curso
maker no colégio santa cruz
talvez o braille pudesse te dá um
projeto interessante
então a gente começou a pensar em idéias
quente poderia criar a partir do que a
ensinou pra gente decidiu que é um
relógio onde estaria a sentir o horário
a gente começou a pesquisar achando
teriam milhares de presentes disso aí
pegaram na internet estaria pronto com o
estado os motores ea gente ter um
relógio mas vi que não tinha internet
também decidiu criar o nosso próprio
a gente começou a pesquisar aprender
sobre robótica e programação dos nossos
professores e tentar montar o relógio
então a gente pegar os motores conectou
com alguns pinos e escrevemos um
programa que levantaria os motores nos
pinos e mostrariam as horas e os minutos
em braile para você poder sentir por um
tempo não funcionou os motores só
tremiam e nada acontecer a gente
escreveu tudo diz cleiton e reconectando
tudo e começou a funcionar
ah e mais ou menos um mês atrás a gente
acabou o relógio e mostramos a ele pra
nossa tia isa foi muito emocionante ver
o quanto ela ficou feliz quente criado
para ajudar os outros a partir do que é
ensinado pra gente e nos incentivou
muito a continuar esse projeto tentar
fazer um relógio menor um tradutor em
braile
foi muito emocionante todo o processo
porque a gente passou com isso é uma
língua nova todo o apoio os valores que
a gente se viu dança tias nos amigos
nossa família nos mostrou o quanto é
importante desenvolver seus próprios
interesses e usá-los para criar uma
mudança no mundo
de repente nós enxergamos que é uma
coisa que nasceu do interesse nosso pode
ajudar na inclusão só tinha e
potencialmente muitas outras pessoas
isso nos mostrou o quão necessário ter
uma idéia revolucionária mas é
importante ter uma visão de melhoria que
você quer criar
com isso nós ficamos comprometidos para
continuar estudando e pesquisando para
criar um impacto ainda maior
então a gente queria mostrar um vídeo
nossa tia além do horário no relógio
sentindo os pilotos e deixa a mensagem
de que muitas coisas parecem muito
simples ainda não foram criadas
esse mesmo nós dois alunos do ensino
médio que nem acabaram o ensino médio
está no segundo ano e somos adolescentes
conseguimos criar algo inovador
ainda tem muita coisa a ser feita é
ajudar as pessoas
o alegado pela
[Aplausos]